you seem to have some hiccups earlier
today you didn't have really smooth
performances and this game wasn't that
smooth either it looked a little bit
unclear what was your feeling overall as
the the game was
transpiring okay I mean what do you want
me to do so I mean I take the piece and
then of course he hasn't done anything
particularly wrong of course he's not
going to be lost I mean what do you want
from me I I don't want anything want to
see just chess getting played yeah but I
mean you're talking about that the game
wasn't smooth and
again what do you want me to do I mean
do you want me to to get a huge
Advantage from the opening and then to
push it all the way is that the only way
you can win a smooth game is that your
point the way you're approaching it is
trying to belittle the whole thing
that's my only issue my B is Magnus we
definitely have respect for you as a
world champion so don't take it any
offense to what we're trying to say
we're just trying to do commentary your
thoughts on your rest of the tournament
um hopeful that I can continue to to
yeah to win not so smooth games